he was just ass naked all the time i've
seen a lot of my dad and i just haven't
asked for it
[Music]
i'm rory this is answer the internet i
feel bad for you guys i'm like the least
famous person yeah you've ever had on
this show your entire subreddit is just
gonna be like who is this jerk off if
you were taken hostage five years ago
what would surprise you the most about
the world today youtubers getting the
same amount of money for fighting as
floyd mayweather if you are in open
field
with an aluminum baseball bat how many
10 year olds with bike helmets could you
take down before they got you one i'm
not even swinging at the helmet so i
think i could take all of them 10 year
olds are [__] too like you're not
cute anymore and you don't even have
like a good worldview or any opinion you
contribute nothing to society all you do
is take have you hit a 10 year old
baseball bat it sounds like you got some
i mean
listen it was it was in international
waters they couldn't they couldn't
prosecute but no if 40 are coming at me
i'm taking 30. because then i might just
get tired would you rather have sex with
two midgets or two seven foot taller
give me some challenging ones here i
would [__] two inches in a heartbeat
that's like on my bucket list this is
easy a seven foot tall girl could be
kind of cool because you know if i could
dunk we could kind of have a dunk
contest but i'm going with it with the
two two little people not midgets this
is politically incorrect would you
rather have a dog die oh come on i
almost brought bailey with me today
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh
or have there be a genocide every time
you fall in love i have intimacy issues
and i'm not emotionally available so i'm
definitely gonna go with the fall in
love genocide thing because i just i
just don't think it's gonna happen also
there is genocide all the time that we
never hear about yeah but you'd be
causing them to be causing them bro i
live in america i'm participating in
them
i pay taxes i am paying for these
genocides you got a one-time pass to do
whatever you wanted what crime did you
commit murder
you know who it would be of course
come on stash your limitations would you
watch a porn with the hottest girl from
your high school if the dude in it was
your dad but she's a drug addict now
like she doesn't even look that good
right
but of age we're in the magical world
she's not a drug addict she still looks
like she looks but she's not a high
school girl here's the thing my dad
treated his house like a locker room he
was just ass naked all the time i've
seen a lot of my dad and i just haven't
asked for it so it wouldn't shock me
that much but i i don't particularly
care to watch any girl from high school
have sex would you give up one inch of
your dick for six inches of height or
vice versa yeah i'd give up an inch of
my dick for that because i feel like
girls would just [__] a tall dude and it
doesn't like once we start [__] you
can't change the size of my dick i don't
know if i'll get a second shot at it but
at least i'll beat once so yeah i would
be taller
i'd be taller for sure would you rather
be a world-class dancer world-class
singer or
world-class fighter listen i'm not going
to do fighter because all you have to do
is have youtube numbers now to make
money with fighting like you don't need
to be a professional boxer i'm just
gonna go singer because i'll have longer
gigs i can sing at the grammys when i'm
60 and it's like a lifetime achievement
award fighters now yeah just go on
youtube and you'll get the same bag
would you rather live in colonial times
or the year 2500 i'm going to risk
because i feel like in the year 2500 i
can go back to colonial times
and then i could just go back to 2500.
yeah plus 2500 like no showers your
teeth are [__] up no toothpaste all
that stuff it's gross
would you think they'll have universal
health care in 2 500
that's how long it'll take
would you rather go into a coma and not
wake up until you're 75 or die tomorrow
i am dying tomorrow absolutely because
that would just be awkward like
sometimes i take a nap too long and it's
really uncomfortable to wake up and like
not know like what the [__] is going on
now being 75 and i probably don't even
know how to [__] on my own and people
have to explain things to you i'll just
die and see what's on the other side
would you rather have a chef masseuse or
chauffeur for the rest of your life chef
i like driving and you can get a massage
for six bucks
i'm taking a chef are you getting these
massages bro let me know where that
place is canal street they jerk you off
afterwards too
you just have to tip if you could be any
character from a tv show who would you
be that's a really good question i would
be slim charles from the wire and here's
why slim charles is the only character
i've seen in a tv show where pretty much
every main character is eventually
murdered slim charles made it through
everything unscathed slim charles is
very underrated in any character or tv
show like he just found his way through
everything it was like well all right
these guys are over let me go after the
people that i almost just killed he's
smart and he was even about to be the
kingpin and he had been around for so
long he sat which i also thought was
hilarious that all the drug dealers in
baltimore met at like a holiday inn
and slim charles was at the holiday and
like guy i'm not cut out to be a ceo i
see what happens every time
i'll be second in command and outlive
all of you slim charles is that dude
would you rather be able to [__] any
girl you wanted or teleport anywhere in
the world okay question can people
teleport with me no i'm definitely going
to teleport without question because i
feel like if you can teleport to
different cities that hires your chances
of [__] any girl you want eventually
you're gonna get tired of [__] any
girl you want in new jersey yeah so let
me just go teleport would you accept a
million dollars to be deported from the
u.s
i won't even say the joke that i have in
my head you can never come back but you
get to take one person with you i like
the us like have you ever been to
houston if i can't ever go back to
houston this is that's not worth 10
million dollars i'm staying 50 million
oh 50 million yeah i'm cool i'm i'm out
of here i'm going to london 25.
all right you keep lowering it yeah well
where's it at like i'm taking it
i'm taking 25. 15.
all right i'll take the million dollars
[Laughter]
i loved it yeah this i love this series
i watch the show
make sure you leave a comment below to
see more comics entertainers and
celebrities that you want to see on the
show make sure you subscribe and hit the
bell icon to set notifications
[Music]
i hate this
good
good all right my hair is